okay I save it so this is gonna be a
sort of weird synopsis of a bunch of
things that I've done recently
so bits and pieces are joint work with
Jacob Steinhardt who's a student at
Stanford you Chen Zhang who's maybe here
Yuchun not here all right he's a student
here and Mike and Martin who were my
former advisors okay so the and stop me
if you have questions I'm just gonna
write on the board and we'll see where
we get to so the the the setting for
this for this talk is sort of the usual
statistical estimation setting and we
are gonna get I'm gonna say we get a
bunch of data say X I now will write
superscripts X I drawn iid from some
distribution P and our goal is to
estimate some quantity mmm
or some statistic say theta of this
distribution okay so this might be like
we just want to estimate the mean of our
distribution or the mean of our
observations but the trick in this talk
and this sort of setting we're working
in is that we only we never actually get
to observe the excise fully we're gonna
observe something else which is a result
of putting some kinds of constraints on
our inferential procedures okay so we
only observe Z I instead of X I and so
an example where you might see something
like that is say in if you had like
distributed system and you were
collecting data remotely and you had
some kind of communication constraints
or bandwidth constraints maybe you can't
send your full observations you send
some restricted version or we might be
doing something with privacy where you
know people don't trust me to collect
data so they don't want to tell me the
truth about themselves I get some
perturbed version of the true data okay
but so the there's sort of a the picture
that we're gonna and and so what we'd
like to understand is what what effect
does observing some something instead of
the excise have on our ability to
estimate things so let's um let's draw a
picture and this will be kind of the
foundation for for the talk
so the the setting throughout is that
we're gonna just assume that we draw
some V in the set script V uniformly at
random and then conditional on seeing V
we generate data okay additional on the
generate X by iid alright and then the
and then the picture is that we actually
don't get to observe these we observe Z
so we have some kind of graphical model
where we have V generates x1 and that
becomes the some sort of channel or
other becomes z1 and then V generates X
2 which becomes z2 and these can depend
on one another and we're gonna repeat
this and times until we get to Z n okay
david uniformly at random
yeah so we're just gonna say that I mean
this that this will be sort of we're
gonna try to show that there are lower
bounds on our ability to reconstruct V
so we're gonna say nature chooses some V
at random and we want to understand what
effect does passing things through this
additional channel have on our ability
to recover the as opposed to what we
could do if we actually observed the
truth
so the goal is based on the CI recover
alright and so the the inside well it's
not really an insight maybe for this
audience but what we're gonna the tools
were going to use to do this is that our
ability to do this is controlled by how
much you know information the Z's
actually carry about V in a in an
information theoretic sense and so the
whole game is to control something like
the mutual information between Z 1 to N
and V by some kind of properties of
these channels and the insight is that
we can do this and by basically assuming
that there's some kind of likelihood
ratio bound on parts of these channels
and we'll see how this comes out in the
next couple minutes so so the what we're
gonna what we're gonna do is say that if
we have bounds on the likelihood ratio
which I will define shortly in our
system we can do this
and in particular we're gonna look at
two kinds of likelihood ratio bounds so
so what we're gonna have is the first
version is we're going to assume say if
we have P of x given V divided by P of x
given V prime is less than or equal to e
to the Alpha for some alpha or we could
say that you're will call this will not
worry about that we'll say P or P of Z
given X divided by P of Z given X prime
is less than or equal to e to the Alpha
so if there's any alpha for which either
of these hold we're going to be able to
prove interesting things so where might
this this will come up in constructions
that we do and what we'll see is that a
and this say if you've seen has anyone
here have who here has seen differential
privacy many of you that almost everyone
has so this this for example would come
up in privacy where you say you know no
matter what the initial data is X or X
prime what I release has to sort of look
the same at the outset so this might
come up in some sort of like privacy
constraint settings and this one we will
construct examples
and the main the main results that is
what minimizing the probability of a
wrong guess of big we could say that I'm
not weird I'm not gonna being a little
bit vague about exactly what we want to
do but yeah you could say we want to
minimize the probability of error in
recovering fee and understand lower
bounds on that probability of error so
that's one thing we might want to do
well given I'll give an example later of
estimating a sparse mean and we'll see
how we can formulate that in this
framework okay all right and the sort of
flavor of results that we're gonna see
is the following is that anytime you
have some kind of likelihood ratio bound
on any part of the channel you're gonna
get a strong data processing inequality
of the following form you'll see that in
case say one we'll call this two in case
one we get something like the neutral
information between Z and V is less than
or equal to some constant c1 times e to
the Alpha minus one squared times the
mutual information between X and the
okay so whatever information there was
between X that X captures about the
system we've lost some factor that looks
like e to the Alpha minus one squared +
some constant thing and in the other
case X could be yes X is the entire
sample so it could be it could be x1 to
xn or we could do this yeah we'll make
it here we'll do it this way X 1 to N
and V and we'll make this Z 1 to N this
constant will change depending on the
problem and then in the other case when
we have this we get a result of the form
I Z 1 to N and V will be less than some
other constant that depends on our
problem again times the same thing
sections 1 & 2 those are the vector is
that the vector is e given the vector X
yeah sorry let's write this this way and
this way X I prime yeah so each
individual example is bounded by alpha
yeah yes there's some depend there's
some dependency and see on say the
dimensionality of things but there's no
dependence on N or on alpha right but I
mean getting getting appropriate sees is
what's gonna tell us things but the
point is I guess that there's some kind
of strong contraction here where we can
where we're losing a lot of the
information that might have initially
been in the problem and I'm sorry this
one was sorry I did this one wrong
what's that
this one I meant the information between
Z and X in this case
okay but let me give let me get go
through a cup one example of this and
that might make it clear exactly why we
care about doing something like this
Robert they're gonna be problem
dependent so they may they may have some
dependence on dimension you know and
we'll well I'll show you an example
where they do have a strong dependence
on dimension although usually is
somewhere between zero and one but you
know it could be it could be anything
the goal is to recover V yes that's
exactly right we're gonna get results to
say this is hard to do as soon as we
have constraints on our channel and what
they I mean look at what this is going
to tell us is that if you want to say
have privacy it's gonna be hard to
actually infer things about the real
world or in that in another case what
the example I'll go through in this talk
is that if there are communication
constraints it's hard to do inference of
V so let me um let me give a theorem and
a consequence that will maybe make a
little bit more explicit these kinds of
results so we'll see because the
constants are super important yeah yeah
yeah yeah I agree with that
so these constants are problem dependent
yeah I mean this is this is the flavor
of results I'll give you one where I'm
being very explicit in a second how's
that okay all right so let's um let's
give one explicit theorem to make
everyone equally unhappy so let's
suppose
he is chosen uniformly at random and
assigned indices from one to D so we're
gonna be looking at some kind of D
dimensional type of problem okay and
what are excise the D dimensional random
vectors excuse me and assume that the
density or the distribution it doesn't
really matter
P of X i given V divided by P of X i
given V prime is less than or equal to
sum each of the Alpha okay and
conditional on the the coordinates
XJ are independent okay so what's the
game the game is that we draw a back
some V in one to D uniformly at random
and then we assume that there's this
bounded likelihood ratio where alpha is
some constant and we have independent
coordinates then what we can show is the
following result so P it doesn't make an
if we want to be we could write DP and
make these radon Nicodemo t'v yeah if
that if that makes you happier but it
really doesn't matter
this can be discrete they can be
densities I don't actually need them to
be an RD they can be in an abstract
space but let's just leave it let's
assume let's just call them densities
and call it a day so sorry now I get
subscript emerging yes X I is a vector X
I 1 through X I D in R to the D so that
that's a conditional probability or
density yes it's on that it can be on
each component or it can be on the
entire vector it doesn't actually matter
for this result yes yeah okay but so
that's it let's let's have this is our
set up then the result is the following
then for any any index J actually we
don't even need this where's right then
the following is true one the average
over the coordinates of the KL
divergence between P of Z 1 to N given
the equals J from P of Z 1 to n given
the equals minus J ok so this is the
average divergence across our entire
thing is going to be bounded by the
following - e to the alpha divided by
the dimension times e to the Alpha minus
1 squared times the sum from I equals 1
to N of the mutual information between X
I and Zi given Z 1 to I minus 1 ok so
let's unpack this statement a tiny bit
so if we if we squint at this what what
is this saying it's saying that the
distance the average distance between
the distributions of what we observe is
related to however much information Z
actually carries about X right because
this is the amount of information Z will
carry about X and the entire problem
their own agree with that this is a sum
of natural formations but it's really
Street by a factor of about alpha
squared and divided by the dimension so
we're losing essentially a factor of the
dimension here as to what we would have
originally had in our problem
so you might say okay why does this
matter why do we care about something
like this so let me give an example
application of this theorem and we will
will you'll see kind of maybe an
interesting consequence so one
consequence of this type of result is
that under memory constraints high
dimensional estimation is hard what's
special about the symmetry I'm and B I
guess it wouldn't really matter I could
kind of put any sort of fees in there
the symmetry will be nice for us when I
give this consequence very arbitrary
pairings yeah is the in the size of the
alphabet a very important couple with
the dimension of X yes but I don't see
how that coupling happens right yeah
let's give an example how does that
sound all right so let's say that let's
let our vectors X be in minus 1 1 to the
D and say that e the expectation of XJ
given V is equal to 0 if V is not in
plus minus J and otherwise it's going to
be Delta or minus Delta if V equals J
and if V equals minus J what's that
that's a delta
not a function of JL okay so now so
basically what I'm saying is that ye of
X given D equals J is just Delta times
the J of basis vector okay so we have it
so basically we have a mean with one
nonzero component alright and let's say
I want to estimate this mean based on an
observation so what what is the what is
what is sort of modern high dimensional
statistics tell us well the dependence
on the dimension should be limited right
there's only one nonzero component
somehow we don't feel like we should
need very much data right but we have a
about the font but here's the here's the
following result so then we what sort of
a standard result in statistics say is
that expectation over all possible
estimators say theta hat based on Z 1 to
n minus y of X given D so let's say I
want to estimate this this is going to
be bigger than or equal to Delta squared
over 2 times 1 minus the square root of
the sum from J equals 1 to D of the KL
divergence between P of Z 1 to N given V
equals J and P of Z 1 to N given V
equals minus J
all right so the point is that
estimation in this model is going to be
somehow the closer the distributions on
Z are the harder estimation is going to
be right yeah question this is this is a
consequence of Pinsky's inequality
basically it's if we could estimate this
well we could test which index we were
at and our error would be Delta squared
I'm not going to prove this inequality
but then yes it's just centrally just a
testing inequality no this is just
something that's true by this is the
calm actually yeah the theorem is
debatable that one is this thing is
accurate but so why does this but so
let's let's now looking at this let's
stick our the result of our theorem in
there okay so in this situation well our
vectors X are just Bernoulli random
variables right so we notice that P of
XJ equals 1 woopsie given V is in it's
gonna be one of 1 plus Delta over 2 1
minus Delta over 2 and 1/2 right I mean
because these are just a bunch of
Bernoulli coordinates with some slight
bias then what we see is that P of XJ
equals anything say given 1 divided by V
or given V
it's less than or equal to 1 plus Delta
over 1 minus Delta which is say less
than or equal to e to the 3 Delta if
Delta is less than equal to 1/2 right so
we actually have this likelihood ratio
bound in this scenario because it the
way we've constructed things so we're
trying to estimate a sparse mean and we
have this likelihood ratio bound now we
can apply our theorem and what do we get
we get that the expectation of the error
for any estimator for the expectation of
X given D is going to be greater than or
equal to Delta squared over 2 times 1
minus the square root of this quantity
here right so we've got 2 e to the 3
Delta divided by D times e to the 3
Delta minus 1 squared and the sum of the
mutual information
right so that's just plugging in our
theorem and now once we've got this if
you squint at this a little bit let's
let's try to unpack what this means so
suppose we had some kind of constraint
on communication in this system
all right so suppose that
so what was that Zi it's restricted to
the bits okay so suppose I can only
communicate B bits out of my system
right now what is can anybody tell me an
upper bound on the mutual information
between Zi and X I in this scenario is
that I heard that somewhere
B yeah B bits 2 to the D values yeah so
then we know that the information that
Zi can actually carry about any of the
excise is gonna be bounded by B right
and so if we stick this in here and I'm
gonna say I'm gonna sort of squint and
say that this is about equal to Delta
squared is everybody ok with that that's
true for small Delta we said Delta was
less than equal to 1/2 anyway right so
if we squint a little bit then we get
that our estimation error for this
sparse mean is greater than or equal to
with some constant factor fudging Delta
squared times 1 minus the square root of
Delta squared times n divided by D times
the bit size B right everybody buy this
one so then once we've got that we can
choose Delta to be whatever we want and
so if we just choose Delta square it to
be the minimum of 1/2 say and D divided
by BN then we get that the expected
error of any estimator in this memory
constrained problem or communication
constraint problem
is greater than or equal to something
like the minimum of 1/2 and D divided by
the x at
all right so why is this an interesting
result this is an interesting result
because classical will not classical
sort of modern high dimensional
statistics tells us that statistically
the number of observations we need
scales only as log the dimension right
and so here so you might expect okay you
know if I could get away with sample
size scaling only logarithmically in the
dimension maybe I don't need to
communicate a whole lot especially if
I'm allowed to keep in memory all of the
previous communications I've done right
because we saw our picture earlier was
that you could have z1 which couldn't
inform z2 which could inform z3 etc but
this says that unless the number of bits
were communicating at each step is
scaling at least almost linearly in the
dimension we're never gonna have an
error rate that's going to go to zero in
a high dimensional statistical setting
so I think my time is basically up now
sorry that was kind of a blitz through
everything but I guess the the take-home
here is that you know if we have some
control over a likelihood ratio anywhere
in a Markov chain we can get strong data
processing inequalities which will give
us interesting lower bounds on
estimation problems as soon as we have
constraints so I'll stop there and
thanks for your attention
don't there's something I can choose to
optimize the bound over even by the
model death is given by the model but I
can choose the model right I'm proving a
lower bounce I'm allowed to do whatever
I want
the board oh well okay so I can choose
everything I'm doing theory right isn't
that what we do right so so if Delta is
given as part of the model then yeah
things things change a little bit but if
I can choose that so if I'm just trying
to prove a lower bound on sparse
estimation then I'm allowed to choose
sort of the signal size and things like
that or that the size of the the non
zero means yeah so I can choose Delta in
that case yes right
right yeah so the so the quadratic thing
is important here to get the sharp rates
yes yes it's a very strong constraint
yeah no these are super strong
constraints but yeah so they're slightly
stronger than a de Bruijn thing because
we're squaring things and we're getting
some kind of dimension dependence in
these results but yeah Tom these things
and you study you rate constraints and
the ability to basically infer that
they have say that it's somewhat
conversion because it can be
characterized precisely when the cubital
these in terms of the community tensions
marketers truncated processes right
I mean I think I think that the setting
is somewhat different than the pure
Gaussian CEO problem sorry that then
that CEO problem it's a it's a little
bit different but here's a single copy
of B it's a it's a one-shot kind of
thing so we don't get quite the same
asymptotics that we're allowed to play
with which is I mean it's the it's
because we're doing just a statistical
estimation rather than but guys you can
leave it to the discussion section yeah
all right